hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll I
understand that people have been doing a
lot of cooking recently more cooking
than usual sourdough bread seems to be
the thing that people have caught onto
as an interesting thing to tackle I have
no idea why that thing in particular I
mean good for you if you're making bread
out there it's not my thing but the idea
of creating something in the kitchen is
kind of my thing I'm not especially good
at it but it appeals to me as both sort
of creative and scientific at the same
time and in that vein we have a great
guest today in Kenji Lopez alt who is
both a wonderful chef and food writer
and also someone very scientifically
inclined he's a very mindscape kind of
chef kenchi got a degree from MIT he's
been writing for a long time for the
Serious Eats
food blog where he has a column called
the food lab and he's actually turned
the food lab into a wonderful wonderful
book that not only tells you recipes to
make things but explains why they work
like literally for decades now I've been
wanting a book like this that didn't
just give me recipes but went through
the science said like okay you want to
soak beans well how long should we soak
them what happens if you soak them for
an hour for 24 hours with salt without
salt let's do the experiment and learn
it it's a really wonderfully written and
very informative book so it was
wonderful to get the chance to talk to
Kenji about some of the big questions
about cooking and eating and taste and
flavor so we talked about the science of
cooking you know the famous my yard
reaction that gives you the wonderful
grilled flavor how different ingredients
and flavors go together and also things
like how different people and cultures
tend to enjoy different foods I asked
whether there's a grand unified theory
of cooking I'm not sure if that's going
to be a realistic thing to shoot for but
that's the kind of question that we talk
about here so this is both a practical
episode you might learn something about
cooking but it's also intellectually
stimulating because you learn the why
why is it that food works certain ways
and not other ways why is it a certain
cooking techniques work as I say in the
episode it's both cooking with science
and also cooking as
science so let's go
[Music]
Kenji Lopez all welcome to the mindscape
podcast oh thanks for having me so I'm a
big fan of the book that you wrote
called foodlab better home cooking
through science an honest recommendation
here you know I I feel in my heart that
a cookbook just like any other book
should be one that you can read like a
book that you can take to bed and leave
through not just a collection of recipes
and you certainly yes that standard yes
but oh thanks but I want to but I would
so I want to offer we're open with the
softball question here your subtitle is
better home cooking through science and
there are some people probably not
mindscape listeners but some people out
there who will feel a little
uncomfortable at that phraseology like
shouldn't science be kept separate as
isn't cooking an expression of the heart
and the passion and the taste and isn't
science something cold and unfeeling
well well I don't think I don't think
the two the two are or I mean I think
the two are orthogonal you can have you
can have something that is high science
and high hearts without the two
competing like that I don't think it's a
dichotomy really and I'll see us so in
some sense that you know that title is
obviously a little bit ironic you know
it's it's uh it's um it's meant to sound
you know it calls back like you know
better better living through science
it's a it's a reference to two older and
ad slogans I first of all I don't think
that science and heart as you put it are
or two you know or they're not a
dichotomy it's not a scale where if you
lose use if you get more of when you
lose the other
you can have high science and high heart
high emotion you know and in fact I
think they actually help each other you
know the whole point of of science is to
give us sort of a an understanding of
how things work if through a certain
process you know science is a process
it's a process of under of examining the
world around us and and getting a better
understanding of how it works and I
think the better you understand how food
and cooking works you know or or how
it's sort of like how if you're trying
to paint a picture you know if you're an
artist you're trying to paint a picture
the better your understanding of color
and how color mixes or the technical
aspects of the medium you're working in
better you understand that the more
easily you are able to
express what is in your head you know so
so for instance like I'm trying to teach
my daughter how to play an instrument
right now or even better like I so like
I I grew up playing violin right and
ever since I was a little kid and so
with violin I'm at this point where it's
like if I hear something in my head it
translates directly to my fingers like I
can play that I can play what I hear
whereas with guitar I've only been
playing it for since I was a teenager so
I don't have that kind of instinctual
understanding of it yeah so when I when
I when I'm playing guitar it's like I
hear something in my head and then I
have to really think about right now how
do I translate that into motions and my
fingers to get that sound to come out
and so there's a level of there's a
level of differentiation between my
brain and what my body does and and you
know if I was a completely beginner
musician and I had never played in
history at all in my life then that
level that distance would be even bigger
so even more difficult for me to put
into the physical expression what I what
I hear in my head so you know so those
those are that's I think the difference
between science and art or science and
heart is that like the art in the heart
are what we feel and what we think
inside and then the science and the
technique are what is what allows us to
then express that in the real world so
you know my goal with the food lab is
not to be sort of super prescriptivists
about recipes and like you have to do it
this way this is the way to make a
hamburger this is the way to roast your
potatoes whatever it's really to sort of
show you this is the science behind it
and this is this is how you get from
point A to point B but you know you're
not restricted to you're not restricted
to point A and point B you can go
wherever you want once you sort of
understand the science around it and you
can you're then able to think about what
you want to do and what sort of
expression you want to make yourself and
you have the tools to then bring that
into fruition yeah I mean I couldn't
agree more and I think the important
point here which a book like yours helps
people understand is that science is a
process as you said and I think that
there's probably a lot of people out
there who maybe think of it as a set of
facts right instead of right moving
truths that are handed down by
scientists but it's really not like that
at all it's a lived experience much like
cooking is in fact I think it's quite
the OP
it's quite the opposite you know science
but at the core of science is that you
know that
that what that what we think our facts
are only facts until until contrary
evidence shows that they aren't you know
like though the whole point of science
is to question facts and and to and do
not accept that what someone told you
isn't true unless it can be proven to be
true so you know so so doubting facts is
that is at the very core of what science
is right and I think that there's a good
room there's room for a sequel to the
book that would be better home cooking
through philosophy I really like the way
that you know you open the book by
saying well what is cooking anyway
that's a very mindscape something to ask
right like and so so why don't you tell
the audience here your answer to that I
mean if that's where we should start
right what do you mean by this cooking
thing well so there's there's a sort of
technical definition of cooking you know
cooking is applying heat and and sort of
triggering a series of chemical
reactions in your food and physical
reactions in your food in raw
ingredients and transforming them into
something else that's that's what the
basics of cooking are you know but then
of course there's a whole other side of
you know cooking is also history it's
also culture it's also you know personal
connections between you and your family
it's an expression of yourself it can be
art it doesn't have to be hard but it
can be art so you know you know there's
many different asset aspects of cooking
but you know from a very technical
definition cooking is applying heat and
chemical reactions to raw ingredients to
transform them into something that is
more desirable to eat that's how much of
a cheat is it that you say heat and the
chemical reactions so sound like two
quite different things well you know
well heat can trigger chemical reaction
it's basically to just cover my bases
because there are there are sort of
types of cooking you know say like
making uh ceviche right it's like you're
you're you're triggering chemical
reactions you're causing proteins to
coagulate but without applying heat you
know and and you know you can also argue
that combining ingredients so that we
sense them in different ways so you know
like taking raw fish and putting putting
a sauce on it is is you know dipping
fish in soy sauce and eating those two
things together
is different than just eating soy sauce
and then eating fish you know the the
way we process those those sensations is
different so I would consider all of
that under the umbrella of cooking
so making combining things heating them
maybe you know and and maybe not eating
them but basically like taking raw
ingredients processing them in some way
yeah
to transform them into a form that is
desirable to eat that's that's what
cooking is that's a good definition but
but I was immediately this the physicist
in me sorry about that but you know I
was just caught up in this idea of heat
and how important it was I mean it's
obviously true and we all know that
there are as you say the sort of
exceptions or the edge cases of sushi
and ceviche and salads and stuff like
that but raha as soon as you say you're
gonna cause chemical reactions in a
substance by applying heat to it
that sounds pretty science e to me and
it gets us right in science questions of
you know how best to apply the heat and
what different ways we'll do two
different kinds of food yeah yeah
absolutely
there yeah I mean there are there are
there are many different ways to to
apply heat yeah I mean well there's
obviously like the three main ways
there's you know the convection
conduction radiation like the you know
the the sort of middle school definition
transfer yeah that we learn and all
three of those come in to come into
playing cooking in different ways you
know but then but then once you want to
get more into it you you you can start
thinking about how a different type of
pant you know different materials are
going to are going to transfer heat
different in different ways how the
humidity level is going to is going to
affect the way heat is transferred and
then attack sort of affect the texture
and the rate of those chemical reactions
yeah I mean it's it's it's it's a pretty
complex application of heat and yeah you
know and and the thing about cooking
though is that you don't need to you
don't necessarily need to understand the
the science behind it to be able to
apply technique right you know like
there's there's many many great great
great chefs in the world and many great
home cooks who who don't know what
conduction versus convection is right
and you don't necessarily need to know
those things to be able to cook well but
I do believe that you know sort of
understanding those things is is a sort
of liberating is it's one of the
liberating effects of science like the
more you understand something the more
able you are to adapt to a specific
situation and the more able you are to
make your your ingredients bend to your
will yeah
is there some commonality to what
happens to a steak and a piece of
asparagus when you heat them up is there
something going on in the chemistry that
is just universal to that process or is
every potential ingredient a little bit
different well they're all a little bit
different but you know there there are
certain things that are that are common
you know they're so like both of them
you know both both steak and asparagus
and bread and you know anything that
anything that you heat up with really
high heat that contains you know protein
and carbohydrate will undergo the may
art reaction which is the sort of
classic browning reaction the reaction
like that that gives you that brown
crust on a piece of bread or that that
gives you this here crust on a steak and
you know so there are certain reactions
that will take place in a lot of
different foods but you know that said
the mayor reaction is not just a single
reaction say it's a complex cascade of
reactions that you know or not are not
fully mapped out and fully understood
and the and and they and they vary a
little bit depending on what you know
what kind of foods what kinds of foods
you're heating of course that said you
know from from a cooking perspective
just from a from a purely practical you
know I don't need to understand the
nitty-gritty aspects of a perspective I
do know for a fact that pretty much no
matter what food I have if I if I heat
it up if i sear it in very hot oil it's
going to Brown and those browning
flavors are going to give it some kind
of more complexity a little bit more
sweetness a little bit more of savory
savory nature to it so you know so so
that so that I do know even without
understanding the very specific you know
I mean I don't I don't know the
specifics of the may our reaction and
and nobody knows all the specifics of
them but we do know that if you apply
heat high heat to food it will Brown and
that will add complexity to the
complexities not just subjective right
there literally are more chemical
compounds in there like oh yeah yeah
yeah absolutely yeah exactly
yeah it's like it's it's like if you
sort of imagine it is like your steak is
like what is like a big Lego it looks
like an a Lego elephant and when you
apply heat to it it's like you're you're
smashing that elephant and then you're
taking all the broken down pieces and
recombining them into a whole zoo right
a whole zoo of miniature animals and so
it's like it's yes not it's not just
subjective it's like there
are you know hundreds of more chemical
compounds in there than there were to
start with that's an interesting way of
thinking about it like if you think of I
mean I guess we use the phrase raw
ingredients metaphorically but the
literal raw ingredients that we use in
cooking are sort of the template from
which we draw all these different things
by changing them with different
processes right by heating them up by
combining them in different ways by
letting acid do its work and salt and so
on yeah absolutely yeah I mean I always
in my in my head I oh I for some reason
I mean I guess it's because I grew up
doing Legos but I always just imagined
Legos in my head they're like you know
that that's how that's that's chemistry
to me is like Legos being being
separated and stuck back together in
different ways yeah I wrote a whole book
on particle physics and the Higgs boson
and my editor had to cut out half of my
lego analogies because it's just totally
too easy and obvious yeah yeah yeah but
I mean so maybe get down a specific a
little bit here I mean you mentioned
conduction and radiation and convection
so how do these different ways of
applying heat in at least broad strokes
you get a specific as you want but how
do they affect the food differently okay
well what you know it I think we might
have to get into some specifics but you
know generally in the kitchen like you
know conduction is the most efficient
form of form of heating I'm so you know
let's talk about let's just talk about
like baking a pizza right because that
uses all three forms of energy perfect
of trans of energy transfers so
conduction is what happens at the base
of the piece at the bottom of the pizza
all right the the underbelly it's so
it's the heat from the floor of the oven
that is being well partially conducted
directly you know obviously it's not it
doesn't make perfect contact so there's
some amount of radiation going on and
there as well there's not air flows
there's no real convection going on
there but it's it's mainly conduction
and so the material that you choose for
the the that you choose to bake the
pizza on can have a serious effect on
how that bottom crust bakes which is why
for instance like we used to use pizza
stones I think now nowadays at least I
use a pizza steel and and that's a
perfect example of why it's because
steel is much denser so it holds more
energy it has a higher specific higher
volumetric heat capacity so it holds
more energy per unit
per thickness per unit per unit of mass
then stone does it also is also much
more conductive so it's able to transfer
that energy much faster so a stone
heated up to 400° in your oven is going
to transfer heat at a certain rate a
piece of steel heated up to the same
temperature he's going to transfer heat
in a much higher rate which is why he
why steel gives you a crispy or pizza
crust when you talk about then radiation
the so radiation is like the direct
transfer of electromag electromagnetic
radiation it doesn't require contact it
doesn't require air is just the the
waves traveling through the vacuum of
space right
and so with a pizza in a traditional
pizza oven you're getting a lot of the
reason why you have to preheat the oven
for so long is because you need the
stones the brickwork or the stonework in
this in the top of the pizza oven to
absorb enough heat that it is emitting
enough radiation that the top of the
pizza cooks quickly the way we get
around that in a home oven is we turn on
the broiler and a broiler heats almost
purely through radiation but you know
there's there's some amount of
convection but most of the convective
heat is is traveling upwards away from
the broiler element so most of the radio
study heat that energy transfer that
you're getting when you cook in a
broiler is direct radiation from either
a hot electric element or from you know
from a gas flame and then finally you
know convection in a pizza oven so in a
traditional pizza oven you get
convection by building and a fire in the
back of the oven and the mouth of the
oven or the chimney is at the front of
the oven and so there are heat currents
the air kind of has this kind of cyclone
shape that that flows from the back so
air gets pulled in through the mouth of
the oven it flows over the heat source
in the back and then it flows around the
top of the oven and up the chimney and
so there's this kind of kind of constant
cyclone of air that's moving around the
oven and you know the more the faster
the air is moving the faster that hot
air is moving the more efficiently it'll
transfer that heat because well what
happens with still air is that the you
know the the air that's right around the
food being cooked it transfers its
energy to the food and then it kind of
just sits there and it cools down right
so when you have hot air you know so in
fan oh sorry in a in a home oven if
you're not talking about a pizza oven in
a home oven you compensate for that by
having a fan in the back that's how a
convection oven works it's basically
just an oven with a heat proof fan in it
and by Fanning the air around and
constantly cycling it you create
convection currents and that increases
the efficiency of heat transfer so you
know so all three of those all three of
those types of cooking come into play
when you're cooking a pizza you know
there's some times there's some things
that we're basically only one of the
elements comes into play for instance if
your pan stirring a steak or you're
making a smashed hamburger you know
that's basically just conduction that
you're relying on to transfer heat so
first of all conduction to transfer heat
from the pan to the food and then
internally in the food you know there
might be some small amount of convection
as liquids sort of move around in the
food but but most of the time most of
the liquids in the food are relatively
stationary so there's not much
convection going on it's really just
conduction from one part of the food to
the nether to another part of the food
so that would be like a purely compared
ly conduction based food a purely
convection let's see what would be
purely convection based I can't think of
many much that's purely convection based
but purely purely radiation pure
radiation would be something like a an
al pastor taco where you have the the
vertical you have a you have a vertical
rotisserie and you have your meat
rotating around there and then you have
either a flame or heat source that's off
to the side um so the the hot air that's
coming off of that is traveling all up
it's not really affecting the food much
but there's radiation that's going to be
effect that's going to be heating up the
food and that's really the only form of
heating that that that food is going to
get yeah you know it's it's uh well all
three are used I don't remember what the
question was at the beginning but but
all three are used to some degree or
another in different in in different
applications well I guess I don't know
much about the history of pizza ovens
but I'm guessing that the people who
invented and perfected them weren't
necessarily thinking in those terms but
they managed to find technology that
would take advantage of all these
different ways of doing it right do you
do yeah I think that's a pretty safe
assumption I mean I don't know for sure
either but that that seems like a pretty
safe assumption that we've been baking
bread for longer than
we've understood exactly how heat is
transferred whether you're communicating
with your team online or working on a
project grammarly is the digital writing
tool you can always rely on to get your
message across clearly and effectively
Graham really works across multiple
platforms such as Gmail Google Docs and
slack and there's more to writing well
than just catching spelling mistakes for
example like most writers I have my
favorite vocabulary words to use over
and over again and grammarly can catch
those and suggest new words new
vocabularies to expand your writing to
keep it fresh to offer you a slightly
more precise term for what you're trying
to say grammerly premium helps you write
like a pro with advanced real-time
feedback premium features include
advanced suggestions on grammar
punctuation sentence structure and style
right now mine scape listeners can get
20% off grammerly premium if you sign up
at grammerly comm slash mindscape that's
20% off grammerly premium go to
grammarly calm / - cape gra mmm AR ly
calm / - cape but now that we're a
little bit better where our science a
little bit better
are we inventing new ways to do things I
was thinking of sous-vide in the back of
my head as something that maybe was
actually inspired by our better
knowledge of technology well you know I
think sous-vide is something that's not
necessarily inspired by a better
knowledge but it's it's inspired by
better way by by higher capability you
know like we we now have control you
know with it's a technological
breakthrough not I don't think it's a
breakthrough in scientific understanding
of heat transfer sous-vide is one of
those things where it's like we now have
the technology to be able to control the
temperature of a water bath to a very
precise degree and you know and since
then we now have also the technology to
do that with with air so like at my
restaurant we use combi ovens which are
you know steam ovens that can hold their
temperature to within a tenth of a
degree so it's sort of like sous-vide
without the bag I guess given the given
the heterogeneous audience we have here
why don't you explain what sous-vide is
and what it's good
for cooking yeah oh so so sous-vide is a
is a it's a method of cooking that was
well first invented in like the 70s but
has really come to fruition in the early
in the early 2000s so in the early 2000s
was when restaurants started using it
frequently
so what sous-vide is essentially you
take a piece of meat usually meat it
could be also vegetables but it's not
quite as useful for vegetables just
because the temperature ranges that you
cook vegetables out but usually you'll
take a piece of meat you'll put it in a
vacuum sealed bag and then you lower
that bag into a water bath that's held
at a very precise temperature using a
sous-vide circulator or precision cook
or whatever you want to call it these
days and so what it allows you to do is
for so for instance a steak is
medium-rare at 125 to 130 degrees or so
safe let's say 127 degrees is perfect
medium-rare for a steak
so with traditional cooking you
generally be cooking at a much higher
temperature than you're going to be
serving your food at right so an oven
might be 400 degrees the surface of a
pan might be 600 degrees and so you're
there with with traditional cooking
there's a sort of balancing act where
it's like alright I want the center of
the meat to be 127 degrees exactly
and so when do I how long do I have to
cook it you know there's a very fine
window of time between perfectly cooked
and overcooked because the cut the whole
time I'm cooking it you know I'm cooking
at a higher temperature that I'm aiming
for so it's going to constantly go be
going up and up and up in temperature so
it's very easy to overcook a steak or
overcook a piece of chicken using
traditional methods with sous-vide you
can set the water bath at exactly 127
degrees so you put the stake in the bag
you drop it in there and you know no
matter how long I leave it in there it's
going to it's going to be at 127 degrees
now eventually there are other things
that are going to happen you know
there's enzymatic reactions that are
that'll cause a safe to turn mushy etc
but you have a very sort of large window
of time and a very large margin of error
as far as timing goes to get a perfectly
medium-rare steak so then what you would
do is you would have rest in there in a
restaurant setting you would put a bunch
of steaks in at the beginning of service
and then someone orders when you take
the steak out of the sous-vide water
bath you sear it really well so develops
a nice crust you get that mayor browning
and then you have a steak that's
perfectly evenly cooked edge to edge you
know and more than anything within the
the usefulness in a restaurant and I
think for a home cook is that it
foolproof sit so that you know there's
no possibility that you go to
accidentally overcook it so if you're a
home cook who who is worried you just
bought a steak for you know a dry-aged a
dry rib eye that's two pounds and you
spent fifty bucks on it and you really
don't want to mess it up for dinner
cooking a sous vide is gonna guarantee
that you get it at the exact right
temperature even if it's the first thing
you've ever cooked in your life so
that's sort of the advantage of
sous-vide cooking you know there are
other things that you can do with
sous-vide cooking that you couldn't do
that you simply were not possible
previously so so for instance like we
what we don't do it at my restaurant
anymore but for a while we did that we
used slow cook bacon in a couple of
dishes and so that was bacon that we
would cook at 135 degrees Fahrenheit for
sorry 145 degrees Fahrenheit for 48
hours
and what that happens is what happens
then is that the meat is tenderized but
the moisture loss is very very minimal
and so you're able to sort of get you're
able to basically cook like tougher cuts
of meat like pork belly or say beef
chuck or beef brisket things like that
you're able to cook tougher cuts of meat
and tenderize them but still serve them
at the juiciness level that sort of a
medium rare or a medium piece of meat
would be why has putting this at your
restaurant mainly for logistical reasons
and and and partly for you know early on
like we were doing you know our
restaurant I think like a lot of
restaurants early on we were much more
experimental and and and we're trying to
we're trying to figure out what our
audience wanted what worked with
operationally what worked and you know
and so and so you know opening a
restaurant is sort of a process of
refining operations to both suit the
needs of your clients and to to fit the
operational infrastructure that you have
and so so we were doing it for a while
sort of just to see whether it fit our
menu whether it fit our operations and
eventually realize now this is this is
not something that's sustainable so we
just opted Ivy for their practical
advice for the home chef do you think
that sous-vide is at the point
these days when any decently tricked-out
kitchen should have one or is it still
in a optional kind of well yeah it's
definitely definitely optional I you
know easier they're inexpensive devices
you know they these days they're under a
hundred dollars so you know if you are a
medium rare meat enthusiast I would say
then sous-vide is a very good very good
investment if you know but on the other
hand it's like you know cooking sous
vide you do miss certain things right
it's like there's a certain sterility to
cooking meat in a bag like you don't get
the aroma is that permeate your house
the way you would if your slow cooking a
piece of meat in the oven or you're
doing a pop herbs that are worse yeah
yeah you know so it's like there's
always trade-offs um and so you really
have to ask yourself what what kind of
cook am i what do I want like do I want
do I care so much about that perfect
edge to edge doneness on a thick steak
that I want to go sous-vide do I care so
much that about like getting a a really
succulent medium-rare chuck roast that
otherwise I would have to do as a pot
roast you know it really depends on what
kind of cook you are and and I can't
make a blanket statement saying yes it's
worth it yes nor no it's not you know I
I have a sous-vide I have a few
sous-vide devices but you know in all
honesty I like I don't I use them
probably a dozen times a year almost
once a month or so for the most part my
day-to-day cooking I don't I don't pull
it out but you know it's um but on the
other hand it's also like I you know
like I've been you know I'm a restaurant
trained cook who's been cooking for
20-something years professionally so
it's like I can if I want to I can I can
nail that perfectly juicy better right
yeah yeah yeah in some sense yeah in
some sense the sous-vide is more helpful
to the people who do not have that
muscle memory right do not know exactly
how to write it done because it has that
forgiveness about it exactly yeah it's
it's more than anything you know and in
restaurants you know the reason the you
know so the main reason we got the combi
ovens in our in our kitchen now which we
use for our sausages and a few other
things we keep them
we hold our sweet old sausages at 135
degrees and then finish them by searing
on the flattop the main reason we caught
that is because it takes out it takes
out any question of human error you know
yeah it's so it's like we can we can
focus on the other things it's like you
know of course our cooks are
well-trained but it's like we know we
know for a fact that the sausage is
going to be perfectly cooked every time
and we don't I don't really have to
worry about that so it's like one of
those things that sort of taken off you
know there's a lot of things to worry
about in a restaurant and if you can
take any of that stuff off your plate
or take it off the plate of a line cook
who has to do a million other things
like if you can if you can guarantee
that the sausage is going to be
perfectly cooked that's one less thing
to worry about and so for us it's like a
worthwhile investment and so similarly I
think it might be worthwhile to a lot of
home cooks who who love cooking but
don't want to have to worry about you
know don't wanna have to sit there like
babysitting a steak or a pork chop when
they have to be making the salad or
cooking the vegetables right you know
real world like you can leave it there
it's good to go you know whether your
family is ready it should with
traditional cooking methods it's like
it's done when it's done and you better
be ready to eat it yeah with sous-vide
it's like it can wait for you when when
you're ready to eat you sear it and you
eat and that's it the other country it
takes a lot of the worries out of off
your plate the other question I have to
ask you about heat is you make the
provocative statement in the book that
cooking with heat tends to be an
irreversible process right you can't
undo those chemical reactions that you
that you did and yeah it doesn't it
can't help but make me think about
entropy and thermodynamics and things
like that but I'm not quite sure if
there actually is a connection there if
I'm just drawing one because of my
prejudices yeah you better than me
it's that seems to make sense there's a
narrow eye when you cook with that
there's an arrow of time when you cook
you can you know yeah oh man and I you
know yes so my daughter's three years
old that she's super into homophones and
puns right now and literally just
yesterday I told you that classic time
flies like an arrow and fruit flies like
a banana the classic yep it took a while
understand but but I think she got my
three-year-old Nabataeans there there is
an error of time with cooking and and
you know there's something in there are
some there are some things that are
reversible and some things that are that
are not but for the most part cooking
reactions are irreversible
what's interesting are there are some
reactions that are are irreversible
between what the time that you finish
cooking and by the time they cook done
particularly with with certain types of
carbohydrates so so so the starch the
starches in bread you know so the reason
that bread like hot bread is soft its
malleable
it's very plastic and then as it as it
starts to cool down its tails right and
stealing is not just about drying it's
actually it's actually starch
retrograding from a gelled form into
into into a crystalline structure so it
sort of recrystallizes as it cools down
with wheat flour that recrystallization
is reversible it's partly well partly
reversible so you can you can take old
bread and reheat it and it'll get soft
again right it'll taste fresh it's true
with other starches like corn corn
starch so tortillas one of the reasons
why it's so difficult to get why tacos
in Mexico are so much better than they
are here is because corn starch
undergoes an an irreversible Richard
retrogradation as it cools down so a
fresh tortilla is that it's best when
it's first cooked and once it's cooled
down it's never going to be as good
again even if you heat it so you know so
when you go to a taqueria in Mexico most
of the time either they're making the
tortillas to order or they will have
gotten their tortillas that morning from
baked fresh that morning and stored in a
cooler where they stayed hot until they
serve them whereas in the u.s. most of
the time they've been sitting at room
temperature in a plastic bag on the
supermarket shelf or at the store and
then they get reheated and they never
have that same elasticity and pliability
that they have when they're when they're
freshly cooked so so yeah so that's an
example of a reaction that is reversible
in one case with bread but not
reversible with a tortilla
there's certainly dishes like
Stew's or Chili's where they seem to
taste better the next day right you make
them think that they're at their peak
but then you put them in the
refrigerator take them out and microwave
them and they're even better that is
that it's not just a delusion right
there really is something going on so so
you know so it's a little difficult to
do tests on that but but the so the
tests that I have that I have done where
like guys I made so is the reason is
difficult to make test is to do tests on
that is because you you have so to do it
actually the only way I can think of to
do it is that you have to make multiple
batches of stew or chili or whatever of
a couple days apart or a day apart and
so one it's sort of one of them fresh in
the serve them one of them a day old but
it's it the reason it's difficult is
because it's never going to be the exact
it's not like you don't make one batch
and divide it in half
you can repeat the test many times but
you know I I haven't repeated it enough
times so that I can say reliably but in
the tests that I've done there's
actually not that much difference in a
in a in a freshly made stew versus a
chilled and reheated stew the main
difference I think comes down to sort of
texture like thickening and and and the
texture that changes when when you when
you reheat flavor-wise it's a little bit
harder to pin down you know and that
that's another reason why it's difficult
to that why it's difficult to test
because it's um is it's very difficult
to isolate the texture changes that
occur from the flavor changes that occur
yeah you know and so no but you know but
that said like it's like do you really
care about those did you do you really
care why I guess all you really care
about is does it taste better or not and
whether this has to do with texture or
flavor and and in those cases like it's
like yeah you can you know what now I'm
trying to remember off the top of my
head now and I actually am I'm positive
that I have an article about this on
Serious Eats where I summarized the the
testing that I had and I now I can't I
can't remember what the results are but
that's fine because I wrote it down
somewhere and everyone can go and look
exactly I can look it up and what I
remember what I'm from what I remember I
was surprised that the difference is
were less than I expected them to be you
know even if they festas our
psychological like you said is it if it
tributes to your enjoyment that still
counts right if you if you are cured by
placebo you're still cured yes
absolutely and you know that's that's
one of the things that I think is really
interesting particularly about taste
it's like so you know I used to work for
Cook's Illustrated magazine and they
relied very heavily on blind taste tests
for for judging different products is
you know and and at the time I sort of
fully bought into that but since then
I've come to think like you know what
like blind tests are extraordinarily
limited because in real life nobody is
tasting things blind right right and our
perception of taste is not it's not just
about what we're perceiving on our
tongue it's not just about it's not just
about sort of the the literal physical
physical interactions were having with
the world and and and the sensors that
we have built-in you know
taste is something that you synthesize
in your brain it's like you did you take
all this stimulus the smell the taste
the sight the sound of foods the feel of
foods the texture of foods and then you
take all that information and you
somehow inside your brain you crunch
those numbers and it's not just this
it's not just the stimulation you're
taking you're also taking into account
your memories you're taking into account
your current mood you're taking about
into account like the the connection
that you have with a specific food that
you have and all these different sort of
conscious and unconscious biases that
your brain has built in and that's what
that's what your sensation of taste
comes from so it's like you can say that
you know when when completely
blindfolded all ice tastes the same and
and this is the test I've done many
times and I and I'm I can stay for ohm
with almost pure certainty that there's
nobody in the world who can tell the
difference between an egg that came from
a chicken in their backyard and an egg
that came from a factory farm in a
completely blind setting you can't tell
the difference but you never eat those
eggs completely blind run do you see the
package you know where the egg came from
you think about the life of the chicken
you think about what it is that you
support in terms of animal welfare you
see the color of the yolk and all those
things are going to affect the way that
you perceive flavor and so it's very you
know it's one thing to say like this is
what our blind taste test showed but
that's not the be-all and end-all when
it comes to taste and perception like
you know like the the the the the cold
you know like I I I have a I have a
certain affinity for
her PBR which is like objectively a
shitty beer a bad B but to me in Vermont
you know it was a beer it was a beer
that we had at the end of our shift when
I was a when I was a line cook
there was a five-gallon bucket that we
filled with ice and 24p be ours in the
and the PBRs would sit there for the
last hour service under under the ice
and you'd see them and like and so that
was like your that was like the route
that the Pavlovian you know the reward
that we got at the end of a good service
was like these ice-cold beers and so now
every time I have a very ice-cold PBR I
think to myself Oh Kenji you did a good
job and I get this I get this happy
feeling you know
and so to me ice-cold PBR tastes great
when objectively it probably doesn't you
know but that okay is the point right I
mean it's not a mistake
exactly you you you it's totally fine to
feel that way it's like you should it's
great you know it's like it's you know
when it comes to say into the eggs it's
like it's great that that eggs that came
from chickens that were treated better
tastes better to me because not only
does it make me enjoy the eggs more it
also leads to happier chickens like what
where's the downside in that yeah
exactly I love the experiment that you
talked about in the book where you
colored the eggs so that people couldn't
tell the difference and yes the
differences in quality that were
perceived went away but that's okay
because the color of the eggs matters
yeah exactly so which is with the the
corollary to that is that if you want to
give people the best brunch ever you
just add like a drop of orange food
coloring to your scrambled eggs before
you cook them yeah but don't that deep
orange color will make them think oh
these must be wonderful the brain is
just as important as the time you know
these experiments yeah more more
important more important - fair enough
but yeah I wouldn't move on a little bit
from heat which is just infinitely
fascinating I could keep talking about
but there's a lot else that goes into
cooking right I mean the flavors there's
this stuff that we were taught when I
was in elementary school that we have
four different kinds of flavors but now
that's been joined by umami or different
ways of tasting I suppose four different
right right right right it's a better
way of saying it so is that how
sciency is that whole spiel about you
know some small finite number of ways of
tasting things well yeah so so the one
so the four flavors I think we were
classically taught our salty sweet sour
what are they salty sweet sour and
bitter
yeah and now and now we've added savory
to that so you know there there is a
certain amount of science as to what you
know the types of chemicals that trigger
their sensations to us
there's old maps of the tongue where
it's like oh we tastes yes sweetness
here we taste saltiness there like those
are mostly mostly bunk you know there is
there is a there's a distribution of all
these of all these sensors all over our
tongues there you know there's slightly
more concentrated in some places than
others but but but the idea that's like
we only taste saltiness at the tip of
our tongue or bitterness at the back
left side of our tongue whatever
whatever the map said I think that's
largely been disproven but yeah you know
but but you know it's what's interesting
is that a lot of those flavors and the
way we the way you know the way we
balance flavors and the way we the way
we value those different flavors is
largely cultural you know so so you know
it's a child you can say all right
children generally hate bitter flavors
and the reason that we hate bitter
flavors is because a lot of poisons in
nature have bitter flavors uh-huh but
then if you go once you once you get
older and you know it's like they're you
know and by the same sense like someone
who's never tasted someone who's not
used to tasting olive oil or say
chocolate they might if you give them a
sample of three different chocolates in
three different olive oils they're
probably gonna pick the sweetest
chocolate and the sort of fruitiest
least bitter least astringent olive oil
as being the best but if you've done go
and ask the panel of experts it's like
no it's like we want a balance of
sweetness and bitterness we want we want
our olive oil to have a certain
astringency a certain pepperiness and a
certain bitterness because you know then
once you start stimulating those those
those sensors and our tongues that that
that sense bitterness it actually makes
us salivate
more which then brings out other flavors
and foods so it's like you know there's
a difference between what our what our
purely pleasurable and again I think a
lot of this comes down to sort of
experimental design where it's like
you're tasting an olive oil on its own
without the context of food or anything
else right and it's like and without
having experience of olive oil eaten
with food and so then yeah maybe the
bitterness might be overwhelming but
then if you take that same olive oil and
and eat it with drizzled over a salad of
spring vegetables that are that are nice
and sweet that bitterness is actually
going to make a salivate more which then
makes us more able to perceive the
sweetness of those vegetables so you
know so there's sort of sort of sort of
sort of like synergistic effects that
different types of flavors get from each
other and you know it's so like if you
also think about say like like like
Southeast Asian cuisine right it's like
the very simple way that it's often been
so so like Thai food for example the
very simple way that's often been
presented to us is that Thai food has
this balance of sweet salty sour and hot
right yep
and and so we think of that and and and
yes you can think of certain tide dishes
that are popular in the u.s. that
contain all those flavors so like Tom
Yum Goong like sweet and sour like hot
and sour soup or like larb like with
lime juice and chilies and sugar and
fish sauce but when you you know the the
reason that we're sort of drawn to those
dishes is because they capture all those
flavors in one single dish whereas
frequently when you go if you actually
travel around thailand and eat a lot
you'll find that there are many dishes
that don't contain all those elements
altogether there are many dishes that
are just purely bitter or many things
that are that are purely hot that don't
have much of the sweetness to balance
them out but generally they're eaten in
meals where they have all the different
elements that sort of balance each other
out and you know you know so the again
again I said I think I got enough at a
tangent and I don't remember what we
initially were talking about which
haven't sprinkle in three a
sorry yeah the writer and not a talker
because with with writing you can always
go look back you know but I'm putting
together the five different basic weight
modes of tasting right and and like you
say like a dish might have all of them
but it's unnecessary if you if you're if
you're having a meal then you can put
them together in different dishes yeah
exactly yeah so it's like it's like my
yeah exactly so it's like my pizza you
know so I find so I think that a so as
far as seasoning goes like salt I think
is in most cultures in fact I think in
every culture just getting the salt
level right is the most important
element of properly seasoning a food
without the right level of salt things
just stays bland yeah I think after that
getting the acid level right is is the
most important thing and and oftentimes
a lot of dishes benefit from a hit of
acid right at the end it'll it'll
enhance flavors that will help you
perceives things more but that's not to
say that every single dish needs acid
particularly if it's generally served
with something that's kind of acidic you
know so for example it's like a pasta
dish you know it could be something that
has acidity on its own you know it could
be something look like a bright acidic
tomato sauce or a squeeze of lemon at
the end but I could also eat like a sort
of like a rich rich ragu Bolognese which
I might has a little bit of acid from
the wine but I would be drinking it with
a with a wine that provides acidity so
that it kind of cuts through the
richness of it as I'm eating it so it's
like you know and that's the same that's
the same idea of eating like in Thailand
where you might need a very hot dish
accompanying by a sweet dish or a
starchy dish so that they balanced each
other out and over the course of one
meal um you know even even when you're a
kid it's like eating a hotdog with with
lemonade makes more sense than eating a
hotdog with milk right it's because
you're you're combining that that
fattiness and that richness and the
savoriness with with acidity or a
hamburger and a coke makes more sense
then well I guess people do like a
hamburger and a milkshake together but
people overdose sometimes that's okay
but yes but also you brought up the idea
that we have training in this right like
it's not all nature
there's some nurture involved it
reminded me of I heard a talk by a
sommelier when Jennifer and I were
visiting Asia and he explained that
China had just been waking up to the
pleasures of wine for the first time but
they completely went for the sweetest
wines they could find right because
right that's what made sense to them and
he predicted that you know 30 or 40
years from now they'll be enjoying the
same kind of wines they like in
California or France or Spain right and
and is that uh you know when was this
that you that you uh that you went on
that just like five or ten years ago was
not not too long okay okay got it got it
yeah I you know I was in I was in China
I guess like five years ago now and
while I was there I found and I'm and
I'm pretty sure this is true because I
remember looking it up I haven't looked
at it recently but I think China is
actually the number one not just
consumer of wine but the number one
producer of wine in the world
did you taste any Chinese wine no I mean
we taste a lot of rice wine like a lot
of traditional Chinese wines we didn't
taste any any Chinese grape wine though
yeah I mean there's no but that
absolutely makes sense you know
maybe China as a nation discovering wine
is sort of like it's sort of like my
just my daughter discovering chocolate
where you know mushiya mmediately goes
through the really sweet stuff but you
know but but the more you get exposed to
chocolate the more you the more you
start to appreciate the complexities of
the not so sweet stuff where you can you
know where you can really taste all the
other flavors and you can taste all the
different the aromas you know you know
it's almost like you know the more
context food has and the more of a story
it has and the more you can tell about
its history and production the more
interesting it gets right and I think
it's the same with any kind of sort of
any sound kind of consumed medium you
know like like music you know I think
like a single Beatles song is great but
it's much much better when it's in the
context of their albums and when it's in
the context of the world they were
living in and so I think you know the
more the more context and the more story
that a piece of food
has that you're consuming you know
whether that's your personal story or
whether that's the sort of a more global
story I think the more interesting you
can get so you know I used to I used to
have this mindset where the story of a
food had to be kind of specific thing
and I think a lot of people have this
this idea also about you know and and
and it sort of ties into the idea of it
ties into the idea of authenticity or
it's like you know a a steak that a
steak that is that is that was raised by
a farmer who raised the cat like you
named named the cow himself fed it by
hand whatever that that steak has more
of a story value than say a steak that
was grown in a lab in a test tube or in
a petri dish right yeah and and Minette
I've kind of come to realize you know
what like my idea of a story is not
necessarily any more valuable than
someone else's idea of a story so for
someone someone else they might find the
idea of a steak that has grown you know
made from stem cells and grown in a lab
to be a far more fascinating story and
therefore far more interesting to eat
than a than any one of you know a
million cows that has a name and so you
know so these days I try very hard to
sort of reserve judgment and to remember
that like my idea of value is not the
same as everybody's idea of value when
it comes to food and you know so long as
you are thinking about the food and
thinking about you know gaining gaining
some value beyond just the the the sort
of eating pleasure of it you know beyond
the sustenance is sustenance element of
it that you know Who am I to judge what
actually is interesting and isn't yeah
and you can appreciate the importance
and the relevance of having a story
without judging that there's some
objectively better stories than others
like you just said so exactly that's the
thing to keep that in mind yeah I mean
when you when you're designing a new
dish or when you're trying to you know
in your restaurant you have to actually
figure out what's going to be on the
menu how how many of these aspects do
you come across sort of ahead of time in
terms of the way to apply heat the
different flavors to bring in the
textures the timing all this stuff is in
is it sort of there's a scientific
process in your
or is it more you're playing around in
the kitchen and and letting yourself be
surprised well so when when we're
designing a dish for the restaurant you
know the technical elements of it are
something that well largely comes from
my experience and that and then we'll go
through testing to make sure to refine
the process to make sure that it works
mainly from an operational perspective
because it's like it's one thing to be
able to to cook one really great chicken
schnitzel at home and it's a very
different thing to be able to do 120 of
them a night yeah right oh yeah and it's
a different different set of equipment
it's different product that you're using
so so most of the technical aspects of
cooking are done for from an operational
perspective and there we do like some
really serious testing so it takes like
you know it takes like a good month or
so from the time I have finalized the
dish to the time to the point where
we're sort of ready to put it out to the
public and we're ready to put it on the
menu and we might we might do some sort
of like experimental stuff like we'll
put it on the menu for a night or two
just to see how it works and see where
we need tweaking but but there is like a
very you know I'm the kind of chef who
really likes to and and writer actually
like who really goes through a rigorous
editing process where it's like I owe
his many ideas out there as I can and
then I test them and I test them and I
test I'm gonna refine them until I'm
happy with the way that they're working
and I'm sure that I can get them
consistent Co so that's sort of the
technical side of the of the of the coin
I think more important with a restaurant
though is is the is not the technical
side but the but making sure that it
fits within the the theme of your
restaurant and that people aren't
confused by something on a menu you know
and and you know I think my my writing
instead of my my online persona gives me
a lot of latitude as far as you know and
the way we designed the restaurant it
gives us a lot of latitude it's like
it's it's modeled after a German beer
hall but you know but I we incorporate
elements of cooking from all around the
world and it's particularly a lot of
sort of Asian ingredients and techniques
well that implements
fact right they're gonna expect
something that is not exactly a
traditional German beer hall yeah
absolutely yeah yeah exactly and so you
know it's like when we first started we
we tried to stick a little bit closer to
what a traditional German beer hall
would be with some sort of California
elements you know it's like a German
beer hall but not all the food is brown
and white you know it's like we tried to
make things green and red and purple to
just because we're in California we get
great produce and because that's just
what a California audience wants but but
you know eventually it's like we sort of
realized you know what like people are
not coming here just for this beer hall
experience like they're coming here
because like they they read my book or
they know like they they're coming here
because it's like my restaurant right
first personally at least and so they're
they've come in expecting a little kind
of crazier stuff which is great for me
it was like all right I guess like if
that's what people want I'll just do
I'll cook the kind of stuff that I want
to do and it's like so so now sort of
the menu criteria is like as long as as
long as it's something that goes well
with beer like as long as it's something
that's going to get people to order beer
and it's something that I would
personally want to eat with beer and
find interesting Anna and I'm able to
you know convince my partners so you
know there's a good balance because like
I'm super into the internet and like I
know my audience and I know what like my
readers want where's my partner Adam he
is sort of he's sort of a Luddite like
he has no idea about how social media
works he doesn't know any of that stuff
and so he knows really what sort of the
the local crowd you don't follow my
stuff want and so between the two of us
it's like we have this Venn diagram of
like what my audience wants and wants
and what a general audience who has no
idea who I am once and we just kind of
find that little football-shaped
intersection and that that's what sort
of forms our menu but yeah I would you
know I would say we spend a lot more
time a lot more of the early time on a
particular menu item thinking about sort
of the the cultural element of it and
how it's going to fit in with the
culture of our restaurant with the
culture of our of our area and also and
also whether it's sort of like it
it pays pays its cultural dues to the
the sources that I'm you know that I'm
that I'm glomming you know that I'm
taking techniques and ingredients from
you know so like we did for example for
while we were doing a special edition
with kimchi so it was like a combination
like german korean hybrid thing and you
know so i and i don't i don't want to be
the kind of chef that's just like oh
like i love kimchi i'm just gonna shove
it in here because because whatever
without really understanding how it's
typically used in korean cuisine and so
you know so for that dish it's like we
designed it very much off based off of
the book ii which is like a korean rice
cake a homestyle korean rice cake dish
that's often as gochujang and kimchi and
the techniques that we used in making it
in the flavor combinations that we use
there are drawn very through a lot of
sort of rigorous research and experience
in korean cuisine because well because
you know i wanted to make sure that the
dish makes sense to both cultures and it
doesn't feel like we're just you know
like well cultural exploitation you know
i like i don't i don't want to be ever
feel like I'm just stealing something
from someone without actually
understanding the historical or cultural
significance of it and so you know so we
spend a lot of time thinking about those
kinds of questions and making sure that
a dish makes sense before we even start
you know training our staff how to cook
it or testing it on customers on the
flip side I remember reading one of the
ideas behind molecular gastronomy was
that we could actually look into the
chemical compounds in different kinds of
food and find pairings that you might
not have intuitively expected on the
basis of well these chemicals are going
to go together you know broccoli and I
don't know chicken livers are better
than you might have thought you ever
yeah thought process you know I'm I'm
super dubious of that only because a you
know I think as we were talking about
before like it's completely impossible
to divorce the cultural and historical
and personal elements of flavor pairings
and food from the the actual sort of
interactions and the actual actual
chemical physical interactions that they
have so it's like sure we can say you
all right like this this um whatever
IBM's computer
decided that broccoli and chocolate go
well together and I taste them and they
taste good together but it's like
alright so first of all like a lot of
that has to do with the way they're
specifically prepared but it's also like
they the mere fact that I know that a
computer decided these two things taste
good together is going to affect the
effect the way that they taste together
for better or for worse you know for
some people it might make them taste
much better together and from first to
other people make that make them taste
worse together so you know it's it's I I
think when you when you try to answer
questions like that it completely
ignores the fact that taste is not
something that we purely sense it's
something that we create in our heads
and and I can't imagine I can't think of
any possible way to divorce those two
things from each other so so yeah like I
I'm very dubious about that whole that
whole side of molecular gastronomy I'm
personally a huge fan of molecular
gastronomy but I absolutely agree that
it can go too far I've been in places
overall or had individual dishes where
you're like I know what you were going
for and yet this this one just didn't
work so you have that at some point
trust the results not just the reasoning
that goes into it yeah yeah you do and
um you know and it's also you you also
the thing is like you you have to also
at some point realize that the results
are highly personal right it's it's yeah
there's no such thing as like these
things universally go well together yeah
you know it's like they go well together
too it's it-it's like in the same sense
that there's no universally better way
to bake pizza or better way to make a
hamburger a better way to cook a steak
it's like it all it all has to do with
your personal taste and how you grew up
in your culture and everything and the
the specific environment that you're in
right now there's this moment around 10
years ago when I think I went to like
three different restaurants in the
course of two months and they all had
some version of olive oil flavored ice
cream and it didn't work at any one of
those really I love olive oil ice must
have gotten out that was the cool thing
but it didn't work for me any one of
those times that's okay different that's
right it's like I personally love all in
fact I just last night I put a drizzle
the olive oil and
see cellphone ice cream for dessert this
changes everything
in fact at our restaurant at worst I
mean we're not open currently but the
one dessert that we've had on the menu
you know we've had a few different
desserts that have rotated around but
the one dessert that we've had since day
one that is will be on the menu again
when we reopen is a roasted pumpkin seed
oil heist sundae which is just vanilla
ice cream drizzled with roasted pumpkin
seed oil and smoked sea salt and it has
a pumpkin seed brittle but the main
flavors are just vanilla ice cream
roasted pumpkin seed oil and sea salt
which I find extremely delicious but
it's also a pretty divisive it's a
pretty pretty divisive one well I should
say like oh those things sound weird
together I'm not gonna get that salt or
salt on that most the time people who do
think like oh that sounds like it could
be interesting
we'll get it and you know because they
know they're the type of person who is
into interesting flavor conversations
like that they like it you know it's
like it's one of those things right it's
like you kind of you have to kind of
know yourself and and and tasting it
it's not really gonna make much of a
difference you know there there are some
cases where it's like something sounds
like it's going to be good and then it
ends up being terrible but I feel like
usually if something sounds like it's
going to be delicious it's probably
gonna be delicious to you assuming that
the execution went well you know I did
this podcast with Michelle Gelfand who
is a psychologist and she talks about
tightness versus looseness in both
people and societies and some people are
just happier when they're obeying the
rules whatever the rules are right they
like the idea of obeying the rules and
other people are just happier violating
the rules whatever the rules are and
that's right go into what you enjoy at
the dining table - yeah you know you
know what's right what's funny is that
um I'm the latter right like I hate
rules and and if somebody tells me to do
something or that I have to do something
like it makes me much more much more
unlikely to do that thing or to enjoy
that thing yeah and I and I know that
about myself but what's funny is that
like when my book came out over my head
and when I had my column foodlab like my
audience seems to be the opposite like
oh well at least a lot of my audience
seems to be the kind that enjoys my
writing because I explain here's why I'm
doing this series where I'm doing that
and they like that sort of
and they're like okay and I see this
online line and oftentimes I think of
myself oh my god like I've created this
monster where it's like oh but like you
can't cook a steak that way because
Kenji said cook it this way I said no
like that's that's not what I meant at
all but but you know people will often
like sort of call out my name and use it
as as an authoritative proof that the
way someone else is doing something is
wrong which is not you know which is the
opposite of the way I generally feel in
real life it's like if somebody tells me
that something is the wrong way to do
something that I'm much more likely to
figure out why I like doing it that way
well I think this is right change what I
like this is exactly one of the reasons
why I enjoyed your cookbook because I'm
not a great chef by any by any stretch a
great cook but I can follow recipes so
if the recipe is clear I can follow it
but I rebelled against it at the same
time even though that's the best way
like I'm not knowledgeable enough to
make substitutions myself so I just
follow the recipe turns out good and
what I always wanted was not just an
explanation for why this works but this
thing you did in your section on creamy
vegetable soups where you said I'm not
going to give you the exact recipe I'm
gonna tell you like the template for
making a great soup out of any
vegetables in any way right like this is
the kind of thing that works the theory
of the recipe is what I've always been
looking for yeah yeah I'm glad I'm glad
you got that because I I feel like a lot
of people don't get that that out of the
book but I mean you're I guess a lot of
people do as well you know like the
analogy I always use is that you know
that it's like if you think about
cooking like the food landscape is a map
right and it's like yeah a recipe is
sort of like a like a term is like going
on to Google and saying hey take me to
take me to the grocery store here and
you get sort of turn-by-turn directions
and it's like all right on one case like
I could be looking down on my phone the
whole time just keep you like completely
ignoring the world follow the
turn-by-turn directions on the map and
arrive at my destination right and
that's sort of like what following a
recipe precisely is it'll get you from
point A to point B and it'll be almost
guaranteed to get you there right but
you can get you get much more
information if you actually look up and
look it around look at the world around
you so rather you know so what I'm
hoping is that like you know my book and
my column and whatever that is that it
gives you
that is more like giving you a map where
it's like here's here's a suggested
route that you take I'm gonna give you
turn by turn directions here but I'm
also gonna give you the whole map so
that if you want to go to a different
place or you want to try taking a
different route or if you're not
starting at the same place as I am if
you're you know if you have a different
set of ingredients or a different set of
tools or your kitchen is not laid out
the way mine is that you can still get
to the same end point that I get to and
you know that's sort of what
understanding the science and
understanding the technique behind
cooking is like well and also it speaks
back to where we started and sort of
science as a process because as much as
there's a lot in your book about cooking
with science using the scientific
processes scientific ideas like knowing
the shape of the molecules or the cells
in an onion helps you cut it in the best
possible way right but there's also
there's also the philosophy of cooking
as science that you try different things
you do experiments you kind of if it's
even if it's not a blind test you try to
say well I'm told to do it this way let
me do it all the different ways and
actually see what is the best rather
than using the power of pure reason to
tell ahead of time yeah you know and
often time you know for some people they
feel like they don't have that luxury
because they cook to feed their families
and they don't want to mess things up
you know but if you're okay with eating
something different than what you had
planned it's really hard to mess
something up so badly that it's like
literally inedible and I find it's
always interesting to eat the
experiments you know it's like to eat
them and think about what kind of what
might have gone wrong or what might have
gone accidentally right and you know so
I recently I don't know if you if you've
seen it but I recently like the last
month or so I've been doing this daily
YouTube show where I basically just like
strapped a camera to my head and I cook
without really planning it's like
general idea what I'm gonna can before I
start but it's not like I weigh up my
ingredients or it's sort of like the
anti cooking show it's like there's
nothing and things go wrong all the time
and I you know that that's just general
like it's much it's a much closer
representation to how I really cook in
real life then then I think the the
impression the book gave across is
because like you know like I have all
these recipes in that book but I can I
can honestly tell you that like of the
300 something recipes in that book since
book was published I've maybe made like
two of them the exact same way that they
published like you know like I don't I
don't follow recipes I understand
techniques and like and I know like
alright when i make chili here are the
different element you know so like the
recipe for chili in that book has like
forty ingredients and it takes like
whatever is seven and a half days to
make something ridiculous and I'm
frankly surprised anybody actually makes
it that way but the point of that recipe
was to show you like here are all the
different things that can affect the way
your chili come out now you go and
choose what you want to do like what you
what you actually care about and that
and that's much more how I cook in real
life it's like I'm fine with not having
some with some you know very specific
idea of the perfect food every time
because I find that you know foods more
interesting when you when you experiment
and when you and when you when you
decide for yourself okay what do I want
out of it this time what do I want out
of my chili this time I did in fact make
exactly that chili recipe and it took me
seven and half days and I used a million
different ingredients but I'll tell ya
well I added bacon that was the one
thing I added I think that you didn't
prep it but oh my god the Cartman they
can ruin it
bacon ruins it no no it was good just a
little bit like but that yeah I people
thought I was a genius after that I
didn't want to you know like I said I
did not deviate from the recipe but
sometimes but the but the one and one
that's another great example even for
people who don't go to all that effort
because you do you put more than one
chili recipe in the book so you like it
something see chili and then there's
like the weekend night chili that you
want to just get it get it done with but
you give some of the results of the
experiments where you sort of overturned
some old wives tales about beans and
soaking them and things like that and
it's just really interesting that
certain techniques are handed down for
generations and no one tests them to
figure out whether they're actually
correct ya know that that's definitely
true you know and that's that's
something that you find frequently but
you know well cuz cooking is one of
those things where it's like it's there
is science to it but it's also like one
of the things that like most people do
well certainly like every group of
people does it every day multiple times
a day right like maybe not idly
individual and a group does it but
everybody eats every day or at least
hopefully almost almost everybody eats
every day and so it is one of those
things where it's like
there's a lot of science suit and a lot
of technique but it's also a task that's
just necessary so for many people it's
like alright I know this works why
should I care about doing it any other
way you know it's just insane in the
same sense that there are a lot of
people who see eating as a burden right
it's like there are plenty of people who
given the choice of taking a pill once a
month that gives them all their
nutritional needs and they don't have to
worry about it they would gladly take
that because they find eating to be a
waste of time and a burden like hey you
know I personally don't understand those
people but they exist and it um and you
know and Who am I to judge that and so
in this and especially like when you're
talking about like in a professional
setting in a restaurant kitchen
restaurants are very high-stress places
there are very low margin businesses
like you you don't really have the
luxury of wasting food or Ted or taking
time to test things and once you find
something that works it's like you stick
with it right and and and in some cases
it's like you know especially especially
like with sort of old-school chef
mentality where the chef is like it
cannot admit any kind of failure or
fault it's like they you know you look
at some old-school chefs like you know
like like Gordon Ramsay it's like no
matter what he says he has to have some
reason for why it's the correct way to
do it even if he's just pulling that
reason out of his ass he has to say it
and he has to sound really sure of
himself when he's saying it and then
let's just come just that's sort of just
a product of the way kitchens you know
professional kitchens used to be run
like this sort of very strict
hierarchical system that kitchens were
run by and you know and so I think
that's how a lot of sort of like of
these myths get perpetuated it's like
you someone tells you like if a 12 star
Michelin chef tells you this is the way
it is then by the power vested in their
authority they that must be the way it
is yeah but you know but you're not
taking into account the fact that the
reason you know maybe there maybe that
works in a restaurant setting maybe that
works when you're when you're cooking
you know 40 eggs at a time but it's not
the same as when you're cooking two eggs
at a time for your family you know maybe
maybe it's only that way because that's
the best way to get a line cook
motivated to do something where you know
so it's like that you you know you
always have to think about what were the
parameters
what was the setting under which these
techniques were developed and do those
do all those parameters apply to me at
home right now or is there something I
could be thinking about differently that
might make it easier or better for me
given my certain situation
yeah and presumably the same advice goes
to things you heard from your
great-grandmother as things you heard
from Michelin star chefs right they they
can come from other contexts that might
not apply to your situation yeah exactly
so I guess to close up let me let me
just ask you know I think it like you
said not everyone can spend a lot of
time in the kitchen not everyone can
spend a lot of time cooking but everyone
does eat and enjoys eating this might be
a tough question but is there any advice
you would give to the person who wants
to sort of take the step from minimalist
like I put things in the microwave or a
you know boil a pot of pasta to a slider
slightly larger degree of creativity in
the kitchen like you know what is this
step you can take to open up your
horizons a little bit to all the
different techniques out there well you
know what I would say is to the process
by which I learn about a new dish is
that I so I almost rarely rarely do I
follow like a single recipe so if I if I
hear about a dish that's interesting to
me or if I go to a restaurant and eat
something that I'm like oh wow this is
something new the process I go through
is that I look up like five or six
recipes or I'll look first of all I
start with the history of a dish
actually like I'll look up like okay
what does this dish mean where did it
come from what does it mean what like
what kind of cultural and historical
context does it have and and really
trying get an understanding of what
makes the thing the thing that it is and
then from there I'll research a bunch of
different recipes it's like so from like
if I'm looking up like a Spanish
tortilla right it's like one recipe
might have onions another most of you
might have no onions and then you look
up the actual history and you find out
oh there's this like huge debate in
Spain about whether a tortilla should
have onions or not and it you know and
so from there it's like you get a better
context of of why certain techniques
exist and why and why some techniques
might differ from the other and that and
then you know by getting a better
understanding of a food you can then
sort of place it in context of your own
life and understand what it is that you
want out of it
and you might be able to sort of
identify like a few key cooking
processes that are different from recipe
to recipe and start to think about why
they might be different and you know
give if you have the capacity in the
time and the patience you can try it try
it multiple ways um you know but it's
the same as like learning about have
anything it's like you just got to kind
of practice and be smart about the way
you think about it you know that sounds
good um do you have that there would be
a that would be of my advice practice
and be smart well that's very good
advice for many many different things do
you have in mind what I thought of
another question do you have in mind
would you would be your final meal if
you have to choose yeah well it could be
a few I mean I would say get right now
my you know it would be it would be
dumplings in Mapo tofu like not not like
traditional is it the way my mom made
them so like like Japanese gyoza that my
mom made out of like she would she would
take leftover beef from hamburgers I
think and mix it with whatever French
scraps she had and then Japanese style
Mapo tofu which is not spicy and is made
with sake and sugar and I think she used
actually I think she used the dumpling
filling in the muff let's go fugu but
everything about it would be something I
grew up eating exactly that makes
perfect sense what does that go well
with beer it goes well with Cal Cal piss
which is like a Japanese yogurt drink oh
okay I'm not familiar with that all
right good something more to discover
well anyway lots to discover here Kenji
Lopez alt that was really fantastic
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast well thanks for having
me
[Music]
you
[Music]